last week I told you about this very
very strange Donald Trump speech where
he described a video about cash being
unloaded from a u.s. plane in Iran our
first reaction was is Trump describing
classified videos that he is now being
shown or told about because he is
getting classified security briefings as
the official Republican nominee later we
realized that actually he just
completely misunderstood what he even
saw he actually saw a video of a plane
in Switzerland not a plane in Iran and
many people are now surprised because
Donald Trump has backtracked about this
actually admitting he didn't know what
the hell he was talking about we
wondered was this in competence or was
this flat out danger in that this guy is
casually chatting at his rallies about
classified material uh we now know what
Trump saw in the news was video three
American prisoners that had been
released by Iran arriving in Geneva
Switzerland trump admitted the error in
a tweet we will show you the tweet where
he said the plane I saw on television
was the hostage plane in Geneva
Switzerland not the plane carrying four
hundred million dollars in cash going to
Iran retweeted 8700 times liked 27
thousand times and then of course it
became part of the news narrative here
is CNN covering Trump walking back these
ridiculous and laughable claims let's
look at the tweet the Trump sent out a
short time ago on this video's is the
plane I saw on television was the
hostage plane in Geneva Switzerland not
the plane carrying four hundred million
dollars in cash going to Iran ! let's
now listen listen to his comments that
have been repeated over the last several
days about what he saw right what he
says he saw in that video originally
let's have a listen yep the tape was
made right you saw that with the
airplane coming in nice plane and the
airplane coming in and the money coming
off I guess right sure that was given to
us has to be by the Iranians sure and
you know why the tape was given to us
tellin because they want to embarrass
our country they want to embarrass her
Jake so two star differences there is
comments they're on tape compared to the
the tweet one he says there was cash
coming off the plane not just the
hostages he said in a tweet so when this
is something you tweet about and then
CNN covers it it's just not good for
your campaign and this is the type of
thing we're talking about Louis the
proof is in the pudding or in the polls
really as we've been talking about the
big headline for me isn't Wow Trump walk
something back it's that first it's very
bizarre comments that Trump makes that
are covered then it's the fact that he
has walked it back and every second that
this is being covered on CNN or whatever
channel it is it's a moment that is not
something positive for your campaign and
these moments are starting to become
cumulatively destructive for the Trump
campaign yeah he's still going to have
that that diehard group of followers who
as long as they think he's going to get
rid of brown people right vote for her
no matter what he said but this is
making a difference these these things
are changing things is it possible this
was some kind of brilliant strategy
where Trump was pretending to have made
a mistake in terms of the misstatement
to then be able to correct it and show
how good he is at taking responsibility
when he does make a mistake or some kind
of crazy theory like that no no because
it wasn't really an apology or it wasn't
even that much of a correction he still
it says that the 400 million is was on a
different plane right and he still wants
that to be that kind of the focus as
nice as this plane was and this was a
nice plane as you mentioned during that
rally it didn't have the contents he
initially believed that the plane had a
long and short of it yeah so not good
for Donald Trump